who would have thought that Luxembourg
has an underbelly but there are parts of
the Grand Duchy that the corporate world
has not yet reached the mood is not
currently good in the center of that
world the district of Pierre spec it's
overlooked by the statue of the tall
banker
Luxemburg status as a global financial
center is under pressure now that the EU
is clamped down on tax havens set to be
complete by 2017 is underway but as
usual bankers are looking ahead and
right now that means they're looking to
China Luxembourg is rapidly growing as a
channel for Chinese financing and
investments that flow into the European
Union the CEO of the Luxembourg Stock
Exchange Robert shafa explains when you
are walking across town you see
definitely much more Chinese visitors
jewelries and maybe in fact the the
selection of shops we have in town is
the reflection of the appetite of these
international visitors but on a more
professional way I think you see above
all the physical presence of the Chinese
banks active in Luxembourg
and which whose number is increasing on
a regular basis China is not alone in
hitching its wagon to Luxembourg brokers
here are well aware that the entire
world appreciates Luxembourg's know how
the fact that the country will end its
banking secrecy as of January 1st 2015
is unlikely to change that the Chinese
for a start are not too bothered about
banking secrecy and tax breaks financial
consultant Amanda Jung says that they're
mainly interested in Luxembourg's role
as a gateway to Europe and as a hub for
the Chinese currency the Jen men be the
jhen men be is on track to become the
third largest international currency
behind the US dollar and a euro
in 2013 the Chinese overseas direct
investments actually will increase to 90
billion US dollars it's more than 70%
almost 70% increase and so because of
the Chinese company they going out so we
also need to use their currency and at
the same time so the Chinese government
we really want to make the currency
internationalize so to reinsert that so
they have to make their currency is also
kind of recognizable as reserve currency
it's possible that it won't be long
before Amanda young can pay with zhenmin
be when she goes shopping in Europe
Luxembourg is looking to consolidate its
role as a leading offshore center in the
euro zone it's already Europe's Islamic
finance center for example the kind of
report and I have to say this is the
Islamic banking involves the prohibition
of interest based loans Luxembourg helps
investors get round that by buying real
estate for example which is then rented
out exactly commercial real estate
that's mostly what we deal with the Bank
of China's European headquarters are
also located in Luxembourg one big
reason for that is the country's relaxed
attitude toward banking regulation for
Luxembourg for example if they felt that
there needed to be in Europe Luxembourg
was a perfect hub for them to you the
eurozone in addition if you compare to a
city like London or Frankfurt if you go
there it has a stronger political
standpoint and maybe they don't want to
take that why would they need to do that
ok Luxembourg is more neutral from that
perspective to retire people the country
is attractive to the fund industry not
only because of political considerations
but also because it is small
international and very central
that's why it's home to Jenny capital
for example an investment management and
financial advisory firm one of its
specialized areas is motorsport if you
look at the German automotive cluster so
south of Germany you have Munich
Ingolstadt Stuttgart Paul spoke and all
of the expertise that has been built
over the last 15 years in these cities
and around these cities has never ceased
to improve you know incrementally every
year where every year and in the fields
of design engineering manufacturing
logistics all of this together now is
deeply integrated and and and localized
all in the same region but Luxembourg
doesn't want to rely too heavily on its
financial sector a former industrial
complex in the country's south is now
home to a high-tech University
Luxembourg would like to become a leader
in the world of innovation and FinTech
the state has plowed money into a
company called digit cash a pioneer of
mobile payment technology because the
Luxembourg regulator is very flexible
there and has really but there's a very
interesting dynamic there for payment
companies and Luxembourg has become a
hub in Europe for payment companies
there's a lot of them over here like
people and they pay a epital and others
and so on the first have established in
Luxembourg so that was the reason why we
actually couldn't do it meanwhile the
tall banker looks beyond all the fuss
about bank secrecy and tax deals
confident that he'll weather the coming
storm